i'm so happy oh come on i'm no i'm happy
for you man love it you do look good
thank you you always look good so do you
you're very handsome well i didn't dress
myself yes oh
no sorry
i just felt like you know it's a new
late night show rules are different i
want to make out with you
i mean i'll do it if you'll do it i mean
i won't make out with you
people people do think that you might be
a gay man
what
a what
one of those american gay men oh oh you
mean the island chain the the game in
ireland
island
i uh i'm actually fascinated with the
idea of like of what you're saying like
people's perceptions of me and because
i'm not a gay man i'm not no i'm from
barbados
barbados bargains no i'm s
up here it's
everything you say is so funny welcome
to the island of jamaica
but i am interested in the idea of i've
always been fascinated with the idea of
masculinity and and femininity and what
it means to act gay because we all know
that that's like a misnomer there's no
such thing as acting gay like we all
know there's tons of big old tough you
know gay marines in afghanistan and then
tons of people like me like oh i simply
adore [ __ ] it's just like
bring it to me
welcome to the island
oh my god
you're one of those friends man i say
don't i say it every time we hang out i
always like every third joke i just go
you're so funny yeah you do it's really
it's amazing you do say that
you do